this variety of baklava called Burma is
made not with phyllo dough like classic
baklava but with cotta effets shredded
wheat dough Burma like classic filo
baklava contains whole pistachios never
pistachio powder this Burma chef pours
granulated sugar over the pistachio
kernels next he sprinkles rosewater
although this ingredient is optional
then syrup made with sugar water
cinnamon and nutmeg as well as lemon to
prevent the sugar from later
crystallizing he mixes by hand to
thoroughly coat the kernels the kata is
made of all-purpose flour milk and water
[Music]
the chef lays out a section of dough
then takes a handful of pistachio
filling and places it on the dough
forming a line running down the middle
for a Burma love this size the filling
is about an inch wide and high he folds
the end closed and rolls the dough at an
angle down the length of the burma
tightly encasing the filling as he goes
at the end he folds the opposite end
closed it takes a Burma chef months to
perfect this technique he places it on a
tray to air dry for 24 hours to ensure
the dough maintains its rolled shape
unlike classic baklava which is baked
Burma is fried and the risk of burning
the pistachios makes this the most
technically challenging type of baklava
to make the chef's fries the loaves for
three minutes in oil heated to around
350 degrees Fahrenheit turning them once
per minute he lets the oil drain off for
half an hour then he pours warm
caramelized sugar over the loaves and
lets them soak for 20 minutes the sugar
to water ratio in the boiling time of
the caramelized sugar have to be just
right otherwise it will become either
too hard or too gooey when it cools
after letting the excess drain off the
loaves rest for about three hours
then the chef rolls the loaf to flatten
out the bumps and slices it into equal
pieces but if there's a protracted
battle waiting between your sweet tooth
and your willpower you've got plenty of
time to work your way through a box of
Burma because it stays fresh for two
weeks
[Music]